aimed enough to give us permission and we were allowed to all talk to one another
but you you are uh we're not allowed to play the audio
but we're allowed to talk with one another and take notes and uh if yumi plus one sir it goes
super amazing yumi plus one sir it goes super amazing hi sir hi sir
are you excited oh it's starting oh no it's not starting never mind
why don't you feel that i'm sorry i thought it was starting
you're starting my dream i'm so excited give me my heart rate go up so high i'm sorry
i think mersey's about to join us now ac is the only one that was unavailable for this due to
tame zones ac is currently sleeping right now so it's just unfortunate taming for the darling
but please please don't please don't count ac out yet
good it's weird being in voice chat and not being allowed to spill all the secrets of what i've got
planned oh no it's starting it's starting okay okay i'm so excited did it just pause it says three
oh is it paused on three yeah mine's paused too
oh no oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh okay oh wait technical difficulties it's fine lines it's
fine look not everyone can work out it's fine it's fine it's fine
they're so cute i can't
wait i'm gonna unmute i just realized i've not got desktop audio and they're split so i can't
hear the stream and you guys can't hear the stream how did you guys split the audio i've got you
guys captured via desktop oh you have to you have to make um what's it called a split yeah you gotta
split in obs you can do it yeah that's what i did i'm used i have two tips i have my headset and my
i ams right now oh no hi here i've posed this watch along up that's all i can say so far
it's finally coming to reality it's been a few months since we've all debuted
and it's been such a blast to be your i'll meet it and there's a lot more for us to show you all
slowly thought we put it all into songs and on that note now's a great time for the first one of
the night
memos of the fox is here on the prowl and she is in the mood for something that's
juicy and dripping and red gushy right excuse you gushy oh i'm like i got two things she can
gush on right now every one says it's very sweet they helped with the watch along
and now they're helping them with a big concert they like to scratch our back we scratch yours
that's why we do it from around these parts you know
memos is a good singer yeah that's actually the most is so talented she is actually got
them lungs on her just hidden you wouldn't realize don't be fooled by the outfit there's
lungs under those straps i know
all the damn
her model so bouncy
i love the way eyelashes i know it's not i know it's not each of a rate stream but
you know the light i know i was just like strawberries i want to eat them the flowers
in her ears i just let's see
all the breadsticks in chat
oh
i like her custom mic
oh you're so right it's really cool god i was talking about customized assets today and i was
like i never got girls anything that's okay i was just like that was so it sounds terrible i was
like if i'm not going to use it i'm not giving it to them because i would have showed my end
in screen for like the first time and literally since debut i showed my end in screen and everyone
was laughing which is terrible why do you hate the ending screen so much i i don't like she just
ends she just leaves i don't like star screams that literally if you open up one of my vods i'm
just like me i don't know i literally spent so much money on it i'm just never used the thing
i've never even seen the stingers i never even used stingers on debut that's so much i hate them
as well so i'm showing them the damn god this is fantastic what this is beyond my expectations
my most is amazing she's like an amazing amazing singer multi multi multi talented
extremely things streams uh freaking makes all her own charts as well
thumbnails you name it she does it she does them all you didn't know she sings well i'm supposed
to keep up with everyone's talents in the vtuber roster that i'm not aware of that's what i thought
i don't want don't come to me you're not constantly stalking the most channel like me
well it's i'm supposed to know absolutely everything about every other vtuber of
uh it's been kind enough to interact with me that's right you're done for reform bend over
prepare yourself
time was it hello everybody hi haro something is in my eye
where we have a peak three films
sorry i'm slurping the tea if anyone can hear that no i don't
wow
on her custom microphone as well oh my gosh
oh so cute
oh my god duet
oh my god how long is this concert that is like some built-in in preparation i'm like
generally so impressed with the most of his voice in burrows me too i wish i could speak japanese
imagine us up there
and i i couldn't forget singing in english i couldn't even imagine singing in a different
language that isn't exactly i think we gotta get some japanese speakers for gen 2 mommy
we're being influenced live you heard it here folks
and i swear i saw what you quote you tweeted she be don't think i didn't see it she went on
twitter and she quote tweeted a slime girl oh don't look at me i don't know i'm not doing nothing
i freaking saw it sing it in slowly just putting it into your mind right i will get you a halloween
variation outfit of you as a slime girl absolutely yeah all yours i'm not having an actual slime
girl it's all yours you can be drawn yeah i'll give me the slime girl yes all right i'll settle
i'll settle for that i'm the slime girl we've defeated the slime allegations
i'm so i'm i'm trying not to scream i'm trying to focus on the
the thing things are jiggling on the screen i don't know if what you guys are looking at but
things are jiggling for me two things are jiggling
slime bunny girl like from queen's blade precisely
what cotton foam family member is going to be the slime girl um i'll have to think about that
sublime she's she's playing oh she's slimy she met the slime she met the slime oh my god i adore her
look at her little freaking put her little pony tails bob are we yaley yaley fish ribbons as well
like the translucent such a good design unfortunately it's my turn to sing hold on let me get my pen
lights out no eye monitor should we get eye trackers out of that i'll give every girl an eye tracker
and we'll watch the most devious videos and stuff and we'll see who's got like 93 per cent
pervert rate this anime is lit
you enjoying it zero
zero her makes like a cut out hello there we go are you enjoying it
yeah is it me sorry i died you did is it making you want to do the concert is zero are you wanting
to get off on stage oh i'm asking is there if she wants to go up on stage she's watching this
i think her makes fucking dying yeah we can't really hear you
as her are you alive uh she's muted again it's fine it's fine it's fine okay i'll take that she's
so excited she's so so excited to get off on stage she's ran away she's ran away any segment at the
thought at the concert let me get let me get two pen lights out i don't have different colors i only
have blue i have so many questions for them that how long this took this is insane i know right
they should just like take the the soundtracks here and just post them as song covers too
honestly that's a smart idea they should i think they will do and that seems
you think they will help so because it's really good they shouldn't just leave it here on the
stream no i want to i want full song covers let those hear your lungs this tiny jellyfish got
lungs on her too god dang
as zura is singing along wiggling my pen lights zura knows the words
is zura singing along to it i think i think that's why she's muted
damn
as zura not beating the weave allegations
this concert is epic literally i had no idea what to expect i've never actually sat through a concert
before
i don't know why this creepy is dying for me it's hard to know
i'm just like so surprised like the stage like all the assets
uh-huh light show
it's really pretty maro's so cute she is
wait i left out her little tentacles bounce is zura is there is me at the audio right
who's gonna get coffee right i mean
i mean do not to play the audio of the stream on stream
question those pen lights are being held up by my arms
oh this goes hard
got a different vibe
if i may started singing in japanese i would have absolutely lost my mind
wait is she about to
i think this is an english cover
if you guys had to sing a song for a concert what would you sing that's my question please
i would rap something ridiculous
abc's
i'm gonna sing five bars five seconds i was pissing myself at that club
room in the bed
there you go yeah ice jj fish i probably do american idea possibly i like green day
i like green day
okay i may go off hit him hit him hit him hit him hey hey don't hurt him now
kill him
slay slay your enemy whoa whoa whoa
that's so cool oh no she's hot
i just set the ambiance
feel that music feel them tunes
mm-hmm
i saw it so i saw it execute me i mean i don't know if you guys have ever played alice madness
returns but when this is the vibe when you get low health you interstate of them hysteria and
you unlock a different version like to your look and this i me is like completely making me want to
play alice madness returns right now that's a great game i've heard of that game i want to play it too
oh i recommend i meet darkness way yeah i meet darkness dementia way just like my immortal
i love her mic too all the song choices are really good too they're all really catchy
i'm in
oh s*** execution
three down two more to go we need to add them to the rasta
three whoa they're all singing together
are there songs that support this
what is it oh wait what this is crazy it's not just like one solo song or duets
oh
let's go oh my gosh
okay i mean all right maro
oh my gosh youtube does need anime emotes somebody's using a pickle instead of the bag
i guess put your pickle away
i love the maro bounces her little your little tentacle pony
it is
that must have taken so much work uh to practice so many questions for them after this like holy
crap strontie i'm sorry i'm not singing in japanese no i'm not gonna ask you to holy crap i would
never ask you to sing in another language uh japanese fans would hate me because i would
just butcher everything because i would not be able this is so beautiful and amazing
i'll do i'll do megan the stallion so please what does she want stop
that new one from megan the stallion was it called that yeah i forgot the name of the faking song
i already forgot the name of the song i was listening to it this morning in the morning
i need some japanese songs to sing japanese that's so good
i'll sing that part
oh
what's that a attack on titan where it's like and the birds and the eagles
i will sing that version when someone's like the english subtitles on it that aren't real words
you mean plus
this is cool
it sort of smush her little face she gives me cute aggression
a door she is so cute i have seen the japanese version of doja cats say so it is very good
it's very cute
that's it i'm making the scottish version and getting a million views
you should you should in the moment i want to say so
i just got shivers her voice is so clear uh
i'm literally getting shivers from her singing
you know if you guys ever want to do some collapse i can set that up whether vtubers for you
that'd be fun
emi do you want to sing magnet with me what's magnet vocaloid magnet oh i know what that is even
wait magnet that's really weird that i know oh my god am i aging myself right now no no no
with the luka wait let me look it up maybe i'm just forgetting the name with luka and hat
and miku and they're forbidden lovers i've never heard this one no you've never heard magnet no
oh look a look a nice option she'd be collab when oh my god look a look a nice and a room well
okay strani do you want to do magnet with me i can't even think you're asking the wrong one
you're forget you were singing a um ed sheeran's thing of the whole bit
yeah i want to do that with you my voice is so broken you have no idea how hard it was to get
we have mixers we'll do a recorded concert
you did not even sound like that come off it come off it now
dare you use these these terminologies against me i was there i was hanging out with you too much
that's why honestly turning your skull i would be very interested to see how your if uh your
or scottish accent would develop because she had never done it around me before until debut
and then and then we did the debut mock and she goes her eyes refliens mommy i was like
where did this come from i was studying oh i was so good i was i was uh honing my
inner scott since i'm scottish myself yes on my mom's side and my mom's side oh you're more than
i probably can or then i didn't yeah my great grandmother immigrated from Scotland i didn't
even know that that's so cool i'm here for her oh she got her love eyes on she got her love eyes on
oh hell yeah go little joe go little joe go little joe go that's my jote
the song is really good it is like a song
is this where i see it in me that her song's being mixed right now oh it's that's fortnite
battle pass you're doing fortnite battle pass are we allowed to talk about it tell them what the plan
was go ahead right so i really like emi's voice and i wanted her to make a meme song cover and the
one song i really wanted her to cover is the song that's fortnite battle pass i just shit out my
ass i put it up my pc because i need me they get that fortnite and i got her to do this that'll
go viral i'll tell you that right now this is my prediction live while she was away on holiday but
unfortunately we were having a lot of delay issues just everywhere i mean just um but she drew her own
artwork for i'm getting it animated and then it's been turned into a little cute video but it's less
than a minute long so i'm gonna get it into oh they're together sorry let me show the fuck up sorry
i guess she cut herself off
we stan vocaloid shadow wizard money gang
oh my god rain's voice is so mommy
i love that rain has like a slight valley accent does she yeah i didn't notice
yes it's very very slight if it's her model so well she just
does in her wee babies were jumping sorry i'm a child i'm an absolute child forgive me forgive me
veiler fortnite skins absolutely no could you imagine it was a fucking doing like cash
money flow emo on someone after you kill them and it's just emi's fucking
she's in her jays like dancing over the corpse of someone because she got first place oh my god
oh i would do a ratashi gakosong i really like tokyo calling because it's about um i think
it's a tokyo drift no no no it's called tokyo calling and it's about how dystopian your life
can become if you don't kind of find the meaning of it or that's why i took away from it and it's
like one of the lines that really resonates me is like the grip they're singing magnet are they
shut up i'm gonna lose it you're gonna find out they are singing magnet oh my god i'm literally
gonna cry no this is one of my favorite vocal light songs oh shit oh my god i actually
i'm peeking out i'm peeking reefland's almost i was actually had sumik who was my uh entrance
into the anime world to say the things i said what i said i what are they gonna do the japanese
or the english version oh that's my question the world is my oh they're doing the japanese
oh
cream in your jarts they were creamed long ago thank you reya's voice
i love reya's singing voice oh my god she sounds so like it's a little bit more mature
it's so clear and surreal you know that yeah absolutely every time she opens she sings it gives
me servers uh-huh
oh takes me back
um
i'm so happy right now i like rain's mic mom can we get mics yeah okay okay you can get mic
actually this is insider knowledge you guys aren't supposed to know this but we're having
you can't keep a secret for the life of you i swear to god i was like oh everyone else can
know that's listening into a how many meeting with the girls in august and they can uh have
we are going to discuss alternative outfits the company's being for it well i already know i'm
getting slime well that's for halloween you want any time for halloween oh shit i'm under
wait oh god right if well you just said it was gonna be for halloween she forgot what she said
okay if we're doing halloween costumes i'm gonna need to pull some strings
if you guys want halloween costumes you must tell me in the meeting because i need to i want to be
a slime girl halloween okay okay i want a halloween costume i don't i still don't know what i'm
gonna do for my alternate outfit i saw you do that a emo guy i think i'm gonna save the gyaru
idea for the 2.0 please remember when if you guys would like to sign on for the next year we also
offer a free alternative outfit um on the house so if you have one idea you like but it's not what
you go for we can probably cover it later thanks droney thank you again insider knowledge
if you uh work under vealer and sign on for the next year your split goes up and further
five percent in your favor oh my god how kind aren't i just pulling them strings
so
my ever self-sacrificing mother
she's shilling
she's shilling so that's funny
no what do you mean you don't you don't like the way that you
rain cloud that was fantastic
making deals while watching a concert
oh strongy make sure she gets she gets so excited
bro i literally leak everything i leak all the place
um worry ac will know because ac is going to be in the meeting about all of this unfolding
so don't you worry when's our meeting supposed to be i'll i don't know august august august
first i'll just put that i'll paint some of that down someday
what's august september october no solo for no i wanna oh she
maybe it was just like short notice
or maybe she wasn't feeling good
mm i mean it's a lot it's a lot of practice it's stressful it is so stressful as well
yeah yeah it is all that stuff done
okay i mean just bow bobbing up and down she's like yep yep yep yep i'm ready
i've heard jack it kind of comes up with her
and cheap bubbles
oh i love them interact and sorry i'm a weasel
yeah we love we stand kingdom hearts in this home
this kingdom hearts good i never had an opportunity to play i thought the plan for october was giggle sticks
no no no i had oh my god the script master got an absolute bolligan and i got a refund on some
stuff yeah as you should i will i'm gonna rewrite it myself i'm not even gonna do a lot of you
well apparently he might have already rewrote it i've not looked at it but i'm i'm i will hold
on i'm gonna take a peek right now yeah take a peek he replaced giggle sticks with a light stick
stop could you imagine is it okay i stopped meaming in the scripts now and it's just like
a fucking substituent instead just rate clock it's going on patreon it's fine
honestly the fucking the the disc the stick on us yeah nuzzle fudge
awful okay literally just took out all of the direction
oh is the actual script usable he left in cocksuckery
i mean if you can overlook that is the script usable question mark or am i gonna have to go in
and do something i honestly i've been i have a bad taste in my mouth although talk about this later
we'll talk about this later concert concert concert business business business business
this is a great song too my light stick burns brighter than ever
i got my light sticks here
go off on me don't forget to check out the link in the description guys because i've
got all their links on youtube like they have worked so hard on this concert even a cheeky sub
and a like on the stream right now i pinned it in my chat just give it a cheeky like let them know
that i fucking enjoyed this because this is like i know you could argue oh they're only singing a
three-minute song no behind the scenes are you kidding me there's so much behind the scenes
and the all while they were streaming as well on the background they would have had to have been
streaming and then like the vocal practice the warm-up practice songs record get it sent to a
mixer edits like just be good to them okay be good be nice and spam begets yes but you're
welcome to spam begets in the chat let them know the reefland showed up let them know the
song in such a long time let me hear them show up that's the month of bread then you can see all
the reeflands in the chat forget and good replays i've trained you well that's what i like to see
you all get rewarded yeah make sure to um click on the link in my chat give them a give them a like
subscribe to the channel subscribe to the girls i have very stuff in my description and all the
other girls do too so wait is mercy in here or she no mercy is not here mercy's by her lonesome
okay she said she would yep too much also i'm sorry yeah because she's like i'm gonna be real
i'm gonna be mad annoying she's probably like also geeking out right now it's probably it's
like yapping a bunch oh my sweet mercy
i'm just gonna pretend that rain was like just tearing up on the guitar
i'm gonna do
starting can you play the instruments uh no i never learned i was athletics
oh what kind of athletics um i was called athletics and swimming as well i um i running
like athletics and the hardle athletics and the high jump anything that's due to their grippers
i'm not being the grippers i like it someone commented on my feet they were like you have
very long toes and i'm like sorry you stubbed your toes so much that they're like fucking nubs
but excuse me i have regular toes if you didn't know you're supposed to be able to walk on them
not like a little stubbly fucking pixel wide like fucking toes like get away man and she took that
purse honestly
harmony is the melody of the heart
i can't stop sharing rain's boobs it's when she bounces they bounce so like politely yeah
they're like in and out
oh my god another trio that's so impressive it's so impressive
you just got the lungs for this i'm i'm tired just thinking and conceptualizing
i know same the scenes
oh don't hurt them no don't hurt them no
i also have long toes nothing long i can't wait you can really grip it with those long
toes you know yeah grip what
group songs are much harder to mix together too i mean i feel like it's not hard to mix anything
when it comes to these girls because they just naturally sound perfectly literally the mix
they're speaking voices they're singing voices
stony can clap real good
grip in the grippy stick with my grippers
okay not
i want that as a tramp stamp on my model thank you
hmm
i wonder what mic she uses raya because her stuff is so clear i know it is thank you for the gifted
boy
who that boy who him is i'm not saying okay tyler go off no no i'm too pasty to see that song
you enjoying it zara i just heard her giggle
this is fantastic
imagine this in 3d oh that would be so good
they'd be unstoppable i'll be pissing myself same
i don't even know how 3d concerts work i've got a clue how do you gotta ask v4 mariah about that
yeah i need insider knowledge come on lads put in come on reflin's pool or break one break
stuff together let's go do the work go on reflin's go on well there was this company
that helped uh utano pandora to do her 3d concert and it's an upcoming company and i was like
oh my god insider knowledge too i met utano pandora before she debuted and before i debuted
no that's so cool yeah it's so i mean she doesn't know that all right she doesn't know that we met
before but i know that we met before oh my god that's so cool that's cool though she was so nice to me
i was um she's so lovely but i don't like interact with her anymore because she doesn't know who i am
smile um but she smile she's so so lovely grin yeah and her goal was to have a 3d concert
and she achieved it oh she achieved it that's so sweet we love girlies get her dreams achieved
achieve those goals uh you're only holding yourself back
just look at rayo bobble
bobble dee bobble dee bobble bobble i love seeing how like they move their models
i wonder what
not uger yet
on core come on get the fuck get back on that stage god damn we even finished it
oh an idol song we want an amazing song together
is that a is that a zora is that a zero can you hear is this thing
are you enjoying it
are you having fun is there uh
yeah
i didn't know really it's a reactive mimosa's ears are they are yeah they are they're all well
rigged um and her boobs too i know i can't stop sharing everyone's boobs
i don't understand in comparison they're actually i have like really bad eyes though so sometimes
mimosa's arms look like a part of her hair yeah she looks like a little nuggie i love it
her arms are very thin so they tend to kind of disappear into her hair for sure
her she's she's our little nugget my little nugget now i want chicken nuggets
oh my god i had really good chicken nuggets yesterday i know this is completely off topic
but it's fucking delicious i was like oh i always eat you i have bad eyes this is not an
excuse to stare at boobs let me alone oh get it get it get it get it this is so hate
yeah mimosa's voice
dinner her mouth tracking is really good
nothing wrong with wanting some strawberry milk get out of here
so
my question is are they doing a five-man song at the end i bet i hope they do yeah i'm getting
i wonder if they'll do like an original song yeah that would be crazy some people we should
do an original song yeah they're like why did veeler not do an original song oh i brought
it stressful and i was trying to debut last thing i want to do is give them a custom song that
like to try and do but if you guys want to like we should all have an original we should have an
a group song that's an original okay i'll do the male part of the song because my voice can have
that i'll do the rap part of the song i'll do the backup vocals that leaves azura and mercy
and icy perfect we're good yeah they can carry us through the through the actual vocals exactly
i'll just do the yeah oh adlibs oh he was adlib everything let's get it veeler
mommy right now taking notes honestly bro i'm spamming their dms i'm like how long did that
fucking take you're supposed to take a week we maybe even months honestly maybe this has been
cooking since day one you never know i know i want to ask the girls after
i want to eat the strawberries on her head i want to eat her
oh look at the little saucy wink she ended up she's like and she knows what she's doing
oh she knows it not to not to make you guys jealous but
please five man five man song come on
moving on
i know i just got scared i'm like what's happening
oh i feel that
oh my god i mean
really big
i'm ready oh it's a fireman oh let's fucking go let's go
oh that's amazing what song is this original question mark is this a k-pop song is it k-pop
yeah what song is this i'm wondering it makes sense that they picked like a k-pop group
because they all have like girl singers of different parts it's a twice song it is a twice song
i feel like i would recognize it if it was a
twice song but i guess i'm a fake twice fan name this particular members grandmother's
maiden name right now oh i'm getting tingles this is awesome
oh my god
can someone tell me what song this is it's kda apparently okay that makes more sense
oh it's kda yeah it's kda i mean why did somebody say it was twice why are you lying
oh it's i'll show you by kda and twice okay my cat oh okay what are you doing
what song for league of legends oh well that's azura fucking happy uh
she's probably geeking out right now hold on i want to go to her stream
i'm lying too she's gonna be saying all the words
well listen to azura singing too yeah she's probably harmonizing with them
oh she's not singing sing for me for me azura sing
she's just bopping she's jumping on the chair right now
i'm saying sing
i'm singing
wow my muscles voice
i wish i could sing like that my god i know me too i wish i could sing in korean and japanese
uh-huh this sounds so good this is a great song for all of them
this must have been a lot of practice my god uh-huh
i like how azuras is like in the corner
that chair is eating heart
her voice
no on core give us more more i want more i want more
no it cannot be on core do like the dj scratch
be like oh last song we don't have time and then dj scratch and they're all like let's go
after party yeah after party
on reya's channel yeah i'm gonna go to his channel right now
oh so so so wait
that was amazing that was really good that was insane yeah dang
let's see arm give me one second reya never more i'm gonna see if we can either watch it if
no i will redirect into her if it's i'm gonna redirect into her how do you redirect without
ending stream uh you don't have to end stream you just edit edit video edit video yeah edit video
or you just go into studio youtube studio yeah but how do you send them how do you send your viewers
like to the stream without ending your own stream oh oh i thought i didn't know what you were asking
no i don't think no no well you could just probably just post a link and be like go forth
okay i'm sorry i'm pulling up the i'm pulling up the link right now
i'm a post link and then i'm gonna chat with everyone for a little bit and then i'm gonna redirect
okay i'll do that too all right i'm gonna see you guys okay
what is it 1115 oh she's not pulled up yet that's why she's not live okay you go
come join reya for the poor post concert crisis and okay i will redirect into the waiting room
for them brief links i'm gonna say thank you to emmy is there and she'd be keeping me company
during this uh absolutely insane watch like wise thank you thank you so much uh um
and business business business and in the meeting later let's not do a live on stream
right thank you so much girls i'll talk to you later all right see you
right i'm about how about boys it's just me and you i will redirect and watch the after party
brief links can i say something really dumb can i tell you it tomorrow i think you already know
what it is but i'm gonna tell you tomorrow the really really really really really really
really dumb thing i did okay uh but let me make sure i i'm gonna redirect into this
after party we are all ears tell us i'll see if one of yous can guess it but
that was a very dumb move on my part what did you do now you're making me curious do you know
okay you don't tell what i did wrong oh if you can't tell then maybe i won't see anything oh hold on
a minute if you can't eat fail does it involve the script tired no oh okay i guess it's not obvious
what i did oh someone guessed it i couldn't hear the entire concert because it would have played
on screen stream so i couldn't do anything i couldn't do anything that's why i was like
blabbing away i couldn't do anything it was too late i didn't know i didn't know that was a
awesome concert either way like i knew that was good sorry you can tell by the by the look alone
it was bumping okay but i'm gonna watch it i'm gonna go back to sleep okay and then i'm gonna
edit mine and shibi's audio and confirm that everyone has at least two audios out by now
because there should be two out by now oh you didn't know i don't know how to split it also
that's why you're doing that little mute on mute thing yeah because i didn't know
um but yes i'm going to go rest please hang out in the after party that was fantastic i'm
gonna get all the the insider knowledge don't mind if the um and tomorrow begins gen two drawings
you stinky stinker tins i already know what i'm gonna have to draw but hope you like ms paint
drawings because that's what you're getting um but please rest well at reefland thank you for
hanging out that was so fun and have an amazing time in the after party okay i give you one big
smidge that's for mimosa then i give you a second big smidge that's for a rare
um and that one's for meru okay and then
that's i mean okay and last but certainly not least
wrinkled please have a fantastic night reefland okay look after yourself hydrate eat stretch if
you haven't stretched okay and i'll see you goofy gibbers tomorrow for the shenanigans that ensue
and this gen two suggestions naughty boys naughty naughty but have fun in the after party for me
okay i'm just gonna triple confirm i'm doing it yes i am thank you so so much reeflands i'll see
you goofy give it tomorrow okay and this one's obviously from me see you tomorrow okay good
night bye bye i'm going back to sleep and then i'll upload the picture and audio